what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chains
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off Joe McGill is the
founder of sidechain and a former
investigator at Secret Service in this
conversation we discussed what the
Secret Service does how investigations
work what Joe has seen criminals use
crypto for why law enforcement is
quickly catching up to the nefarious
activity and what Joe is building at
sidechain these law enforcement
professionals and regulators I really
enjoyed this conversation and I hope you
do as well I'm super excited about this
conversation because you've lived a life
that most people only watch in movies
but thanks so much for coming to do this
yeah thanks for having me on for sure
all right let's go back pre crypto you
used to be in the Secret Service maybe
talk to us about how did you get to the
Secret Service and then get into kind of
what people do there yeah so it's crazy
back in 2008 before we had all this
instant Internet stuff I used a paper
application and filled out about 50
pages of an application mailed it to the
Nashville field office for the Secret
Service and what the interview process
took about a year after polygraphs and
all that fun stuff and then training and
that's how I got started on the uniform
division side eventually transferred as
an agent out to San Francisco and that's
how I got into crypto was on their
electronic Crimes Task Force squad got
it and so let's talk a little bit about
the Secret Service in general because I
think most people think it's you know
dudes in suits and ties protecting the
president which obviously is one part of
the job or the organization but what
else does your service do yeah so
they're you know initially founded to
combat the the nation's infrastructure
of counterfeit currency and that's still
a very big mission for the Secret
Service but they also of course do
protection around the campaign year feel
bad for all the current agents because I
know what it's like they're gonna be
away from home almost the entire year
but in addition to that you know they do
a lot of financial crime stuff based on
cyber crimes network intrusions credit
card theft they're really good at credit
card markets type stuff on the dark web
but yeah most people think suits your
piece and sunglasses and that's just
that's just part of it
that's the the sexy Hollywood version
right right alright so as you're doing
that you get out San Francisco you're on
this electronic task force called yes
electronic Crimes Task Force they're all
over the United States and the mission
of that is basically to network with
FinTech partners
institutions local and state law
enforcement agencies and so it's a very
large network where they can expand
other investigations capabilities and
whatever reason they're in got it and
how does crypto play into that this is
what 2010 or so that you're doing this
but like at what point do you guys come
across Bitcoin or crypto and kind of why
to catch your eye yeah so I started on
the crypto side in 2014 I had a brief
lapse where I left the secret service
and then decided I want to go back for
more so more pain more pain
so 24 2014 we went back and started on
the counter for counterfeit squad and
then switch to electronic Crimes and you
know what's interesting when I started
researching dark web and cyber stuff I
could I started coming across this thing
called Bitcoin had no idea what it was
and then started researching it
listening to all the you know the crypto
og podcast and blogs and seeing what
they had to say and then started trying
to figure out a way where I could use
Bitcoin and my investigations to target
cyber criminals and I found it's a great
it's a great way to track people and and
on the cyber side yeah and what's
interesting to me is we've seen this now
so I had a Petra came from da come in
and talked to a bunch of other folks who
are either current law enforcement or
former and what ends up happening it
sounds like it's two things either one
the criminals are using it so then the
law enforcement side has to get caught
up right you know what is this thing how
are they using it it's not like they're
using regular bank accounts so I've got
to figure out how to kind of do my work
and investigate on this side or the
second is that they're actually using it
as a carrot right and they basically are
putting it into the system sending it to
somebody and then understanding that
person is unsophisticated and that
they're gonna be super trackable as I
send Bitcoin around
at the Secret Service was it more you
guys getting pulled it as you were
seeing criminals use it or was it more
of hey let's actually start to use
investigations but we initiate kind of
the use of Bitcoin in that investigation
so we're both yeah I was a little bit of
Bo so a lot of people think that the US
government may target Bitcoin or
cryptocurrency and I can't speak for the
Oscar Moreno but you know when I was at
the Secret Service you know we did not
target crypto or Bitcoin or anything
like that but we we target individuals
that used that currency to launder the
proceeds with a crime and take advantage
of the victims there's also a necessary
tool to be active on the dark web
several years ago Liberty Reserve was a
big thing and then you have Imani type
things and Russia and other places but
bitcoin is keying its most liquid
privacy coins are out there but the end
of the day if you want to be a user on
the dark web bitcoin is the way you need
to transact and so that's how we got
into it was so it could be more
effective in our crimes and and come
into the 21st century just because
that's what you got to do to be really
good on the dark web is to be able to
integrate that technology yeah ensue
let's spend a little bit of time on the
dark web we'll get back to see your
service what is the dark web right I
think people hear that all time and it's
like this big scary thing but like what
exactly is the dark web and like why are
people using that versus the traditional
Internet yeah you know it's interesting
because there's the whole privacy aspect
of using the tor browser for dissidents
journalists missionaries trying to evade
authoritarian regimes and then you have
the other aspect where you think of the
dark web where you can get on there and
look for stolen credit cards data breach
information anything that you want
basically that's illegal you can get on
the dark web and that's that's through
the same browser and so we would target
specific crimes that were within the
Secret Service scope and then we would
go after those those people wherever
they were at as long as we had some type
of connection the United States got it
and the thought process on the dark web
is simply it is a less trackable or
traceable use of the Internet and it
becomes harder for law enforcement to
find the IP addresses and locations and
names of the people involved etc is that
generally right
yeah that's nearly like the tor browser
has has IP relay top
technology where the proxies or are very
easy for the criminals that get behind
but it's also used by people that are
very interested in privacy as well but
on the dork web side you know they're
getting on the tor browser they're using
VPNs and so they're making it very hard
to capture that digital footprint so
when they use cryptocurrency you know
it's it's typically a good way for us to
get an insight on where they're going
because you can look at a lot of
different things such as wallet
consolidation and different clusters
where they're going in out of and with
crypto you really all need to make one
mistake and then it makes it a lot
easier for a law enforcement to track it
got it cuz really it is true I think of
most law enforcement agencies they're
using money trail as a key component to
the investigation right it's just follow
the money and and that usually leads you
to to a lot of details that report for
the investigation yeah it's exactly
right if you think of old-school
investigations like money laundering and
stuff and it seems almost antiquated
when you get into Bitcoin world because
it's so fast you know the money
laundering scams you you go to a bank
you look at where it went and then if it
went to a certain country and you didn't
catch it you may be able to get it but
you have to go through mutual legal
sense a true mutual legal assistant tree
and M lat with that country if you had
it and it could take years or months to
get that money back but with crypto you
see it happen you coordinate with the
exchange you send them legal documents
and if you catch it in time you can
freeze the money and you can get it back
to the victim so there's a lot of really
good use cases for a Bitcoin out there
and it's not it's not as bad as what
people think is what I found and they're
my experience what um what percentage of
the Bitcoin uses do you think is
criminal activity like do you think it's
a material you know 50 percent or do you
think it's much lower than that kind of
single digit type stuff I think it's a
single digit I've never done a study but
if you looked at companies like elliptic
and chain analysis they put out data in
the last I think year that said based on
X amount of transactions I think
elliptic found that two percent of
camera or what it was but an obscene
amount of transaction was actually dark
web related in my experience it's
typically just criminals taking
advantage of individual
or not is getting their cybersecurity
but yeah it's it's a small percentage
it's not it's not like the dollar or
other currencies where you think about
its its laundered all over the world use
cartels organized crime and cash is king
and it's it's the most laundered
currency out there it's not a popular
thing to say but bitcoins only you know
small percent for crime yeah I think the
the numbers it was like the UK Office of
Drug Enforcement or something did a
study and it was like two trillion
dollars a years laundered through
through dollars which is a pretty crazy
number right could you imagine that
going through Bitcoin two trillion right
yeah because what really crypto in
general I let's call it 250 billion
dollar market cap surgery you know one
tenth give or take of all of the
laundered money in the Fiat system is
the entire market cap of crypto I even
Bitcoin she's all crypto yeah that's
crazy pretty nuts all right so you're at
the Secret Service you start to see hit
bitcoins going to be important here what
are those early conversations like where
you're talking to either superiors or
peers and you're like hey you know this
Bitcoin thing our people open minded to
it do they just think it's all [ __ ]
like what was kind of the reception so I
looked out in my situation I had a
non-traditional path to the secret
service typically you get hammered your
entire career with protection I looked
out where we came in contact with an
individual that agreed to work for us
full-time in San Francisco and so that
person spoke some critical languages and
showed us the importance of crypto on
the dark web and be able to target these
actors and so I had a really good boss
there that was very Pro what can we do
to make the team better
he's very innovative and so that helped
us out as far as you know we wrote up a
proposal told we wanted to do got
approval and then from there just it
went nuts I mean my entire I guess four
years in San Francisco it was just
non-stop especially once the 2017 came
the ICO craze I mean we were tripping
over scams we couldn't keep up really I
mean it
it was just wild and so when you say
somebody wanted to work full-time is
this somebody who like got hired as a
Secret Service person or is this more of
like what I'll consider somebody who is
working as I can inform it for the
Secret Service so they got into the
legal trouble and we we agreed to work
some time off
so but the individual was a very nice
way of saying it yes so individual was
very smart very talented and you know
want to do the right thing and helped us
on a lot of good cases and you know I
feel like when I worked with this
individuals I got a master's in crypto
because he taught me everything he knew
from his previous life and you know that
helped us do investigations and catch a
lot of really bad people and how much of
the things that you were seeing what can
we put in the category of like scams
fraud things that are happen in every
market right but it's really bad people
doing bad things but they're more
manipulating others versus what I'll
call like hardcore criminal activity
like drug dealers and and you know kind
of hitman and things that are more like
violent related like what would the
breakdown of of the things that you guys
were looking at kind of across those two
categories so most of it was complex
financial and cyber investigations so we
had sometimes target you know the big
buzzwords transnational organized crime
groups and those were groups of
individuals that operate almost like a
business so their infrastructure would
be you have a company they have one guy
that does maybe built a website you have
another guy that handles the cash out so
you have another guy that's a Western
Union mule they have another guy that
recruits people on the dark web to do
text messaging or whatever it might be
and so they're usually very well oiled
companies on but are the criminal
organizations and so that's that's what
we target got it and like can you give
me an example of like what they would be
do like so let's say I came in contact
with this company or these individuals
like what's their pitch to me or how do
they scam me I guess so it's very common
on some of these really good criminal
forums where they'll be looking for
people what to do cash outs or drops and
so okay so cash out would be you have a
phone and they say okay we're gonna send
you SMS text messages information and
you need to be the person that cashes
out the money so you may have a guy
overseas in certain countries that are
known for cyber activity recruiting
people in the u.s. to take over accounts
to cash out the activity or to
up an account in their own name and try
to move money through it and so you'll
see these criminals just open up
accounts like crazy really yeah it's
it's pretty it's pretty well and so the
thought process is if if these bad guys
come to me and say hey go open up a Bank
of America account we're gonna send you
some money cash it out into physical
cash and then at some point leave it
somewhere or somehow get it to them so
that they essentially are laundering it
through my name my account and so it
throws off investigators etc who are
looking for maybe the bad guys but
instead the money came out through me
yeah it's exactly right and sometimes
they would use you know Western Union
it's in the back overseas where they
would actually buy Bitcoin go to Bitcoin
ATM it's in the Bitcoin back overseas
but that's kind of starting to that I
think that I would call that the old
school financial network and those same
crime groups have shifted to those same
tactics but in crypto currency so you're
seeing verified accounts now being for
sale people selling their kyc on
Craigslist and criminals are using it
and so it's been interesting seeing the
exchanges shift their tactics on
security and kyc over the last few years
to where they're getting really good at
catching a lot of this fraud yeah that's
crazy that somebody goes gets kyc an AML
account and then turns around and says
on craigslist i'll so you basically
username and password right yeah yes I
say Craigslist Geralyn bazemore dark web
forums but you know I had a case was
very interesting it was a lot of it was
one group of individuals and they
created over 50 phishing websites that
look like exchanges so you go to
coinbase calm you thought but maybe it
was a a instead of an a you login with
your credentials the 2fa would go right
to the attackers and so they were ready
to log into your account and just drain
your drain your money when we started
looking at some of the data and serving
legal process we started seeing the same
individuals but photoshopping their
faces so you see the same guy on his you
know it's button-down shirt or a hoodie
and then you'd see a different face on
it at seven different exchanges and this
was before they are using very technical
data methods to analyze your face and do
do the spinning stuff and so it was wild
and that was in 2017 and so I think the
attackers are generally one step ahead
always so what they're doing now is
probably something we'll figure out in
six months yeah and it is funny you're a
because it used to be the static photo
and now it's more of like a live type
situation or they even want to get on
skype or something right back to you and
and all of that
is interesting because I'm sure you saw
like in Hong Kong these uh protesters
had essentially what's like a visor and
that visor had a projection camera and
it could project the look of a different
face onto your face right now it looks
you know like it's projected but it's
really there to defeat the the facial
recognition software that the camera is
exactly I have obviously wouldn't work
if you're on skype etc but but it's
funny how this technology is coming it
really is and so as you're doing these
investigations like one of the things
that its religion to me is like it's
almost like a cyber war right because
the criminals are doing their stuff you
guys are sitting in San Francisco you
guys are doing your stuff and you're
trying to play a cat-and-mouse game
online in this digital world whether
it's on the dark web or not but how do
you go from like that cyber kind of
battle to okay now let's go get that
person right like at what point do you
end up having kind of physical
interaction or real world interaction
with people is it on the point of arrest
is it you know something before that
we're still kind of investigating and
gathering information like how does that
work so it's really interesting in the
cyber world usually you don't have
interaction or contact with your targets
unless you're doing some type of UC or
up where you're trying to get to know
the person but nowadays you really can
do everything online so okay you can buy
stolen credit cards from them you can
buy stolen Bitcoin from them so and if
you think about your your guests you had
a while back from the DEA and those guys
are doing a lot of really cool in-person
type things that you know I would never
do on the cyber side because it's a
different type of a different type of
crime I can do it from my desk I can be
a keyboard warrior so to speak and and
track these guys down and so basically
your goal is to build up enough probable
cause where you
can one have enough information to
indict the individual and to beautifully
identify the suspect got it and then
once you get the full identification
then you guys are kicking it over to
like another agency to actually go pick
them up or like the local police
department like how does that work so it
depends if they're in the US the Secret
Service will do the arrest and we'll
partner maybe with other agencies if
it's international and depends on if
they're an ally if they have an
agreement if they have an extradition
treaty with us then you know we may not
even tell the government until we know
somebody's traveling so a lot of
different factors go into play because
it's on the cyber world typically the
investigations are sensitive and they
can be connected to organized crime that
are you know you just don't want to mess
around with and notify you're looking at
yeah it to me it feels like you know I'm
personally fascinated with this idea
that criminals continue to use new
technology right to try stay ahead of
law enforcement and then it gets matured
and kind of criminals move on to the
next thing and then everyone else adopts
that technology right we saw this with
you know beeper cellphone internet also
stuff Bitcoin crook is no different but
the sophistication level of the criminal
right in the beginning what one of the
things that people forget is like during
the Silk Road investigation law
enforcement literally was siphoning off
some of the Bitcoin and then got caught
right and so it was this belief of like
oh no one will ever catch me because
they don't understand this stuff and
then law enforcement got up to speed and
said well hold on me you you did
something but at the same time the scams
get better right it's no longer just
like hey here's a phishing website now
it's you know something that's kind of
more sophisticated do you see with the
sophistication level of them going to
what I'll call more sophisticated crypto
currencies from a privacy standpoint so
Manero Z cache etc or is they still
stuck on like where the liquidity is
either stable coins or Bitcoin or
something like that yeah that's a good
question so I mean there are some
markets where you can still use Manero
to buy buy whatever you need but in the
day Bitcoin is keen because it's liquid
people love Bitcoin because you can
there's a lot good different off off
ramps you can you know catch the Fiat
there's OTC desk you can you know
bitcoin is basically the primary go-to
for cashing out and for your proceeds
got it
and then let's talk a little bit about
so what you guys started the
investigations was there a change of
pace inside of the Secret Service like
when you say in 2017 you felt like you
guys were basically just tripping over
scams etc like how do you determine
where do we focus our time and effort is
it just what's the biggest scam or is
there some other kind of methodology
yeah so that was a challenge that we
would get a we'd have a tough time with
because at the federal level you
typically need some type of large loss
to be able to take the case or it has to
be a pretty significant for a local
state and local sometimes it's different
but we we tried to take cases federal as
much as we could but when 2017 hit and
you saw a very large influx of new
people to crypto we started seeing a lot
of the icos were being targeted for
instance one case I saw I CEO got hacked
and I just picked up the phone and cold
called the CEO I figured out who it was
and said hey we want to help you out
this case you know send us what you got
we we contact the exchange we got the
money back for him but that was just one
example you know hackers were taking
over their accounts and then they're
sending out an email and saying hey ICO
is open here's the etherium address and
all your money here and then of course
you know the FUD happened nobody wanted
to double check the address and so
attackers were making out with millions
of dollars by just inserting the wrong
address because maybe they didn't take
the right steps on securing their emails
or their slack channels or whatever it
may be and so criminals were really
exploiting that in 2017 that's crazy
right the idea that basically they are
impersonating the either CEO or the
project and then sending out addresses
and people are just sending money right
bare asset yeah they have it good luck
yeah it was great you think some of
these companies we're not doing basic
things like I always say go - have I
been pawned all the time see if you're a
password stuck in data breach because if
it has then you know you need to change
your password you should regularly do
that but a lot of people are just
missing out a lot of the basic steps
because they're so excited about their
white paper getting their project out
they had their own foot probably because
they wanted to make sure they got they
beat the next project to market and so a
lot of people were missing out on basics
security steps yeah and I think if we
fast forward to now companies are doing
a lot better and protecting their
infrastructure and taking second steps
to secure their companies for sure and
so you've kind of continued down the
rabbit hole right so you you spent the
time at a serious service you've now
transitioned to some other investigative
work but you're also building a an
application that essentially emerged as
kind of your interest in crypto with
your interest in kind of investigations
and regulatory compliance etc baby talk
to us a little bit about sidechained
and what the original idea was and kind
of what you guys have built so far yeah
so slight change started in June of this
year and I was actually in conversation
with an executive of a crypto exchange
and he said you know you got to find a
way to get back in the crypto game and I
said you know I'm a Memphis how am I
gonna do that it's there's not too much
going on here they have some really good
blockchain projects and stuff but
compared to San Francisco where I was at
and you know he suggested actually just
started a consulting company and so
within two weeks had a website up was
primary just gonna try to do crypto
recovery risk type consulting and then I
ran into my co-founder who's now Jason
Fisher and we talked about down the road
I like to build an app and some software
and then you know we decided to build an
app that anybody can use to track crypto
and determine if it's bad or if it's
associated with the scam and so we've
taken the enterprise grade tech approach
to where we're using machine learning
criminal pattern behavior we're looking
at addresses that we know are bad and
we're combining that and giving a score
for any user that puts in an address
yeah and so you've shown me the product
right and basically the way that my
understanding of it works is I am about
to do a transaction with somebody they
send me their wallet address I can copy
and paste that wallet address put it
into the system and it will come back
with a score as to like the risk right
so these are low risk high risk or
somewhere in between but then also it
will give me a bunch of information
about past transactions and and I can
kind of set alerts to get notifications
when money's going in or out etc and it
really seems to me like taking the
publicly available information and using
technology to better one located to kind
of massage that data and then present it
it's more human readable in some degree
right yeah yeah it's exactly right so
we're trying to create as most as much
efficiency as we can inside the app
because it is an app nobody wants to do
all the research on an app right so
we're taking the most common use
websites where people use as scams we're
plugging it so an individual hitscan
we're real time searching those websites
trying to see if they're a result you
know one question of god is what happens
if the address has zero transactions
that's common I mean bad guys are gonna
recycle their wallets but I've also
found that sometimes usually they don't
always do that on the first try so we
may not catch the first scam but if
someone gets scammed and they report it
we're gonna catch the second third and
the fourth and they're gonna have to
keep reshuffling but as they move their
money we're eventually gonna find their
consolidation wallet and you know it's
just gonna continually open leads yeah
so the first part you said there about
the scan that's basically within the app
there's this button that says like scan
the dark whatever right and what's
happening on the back end is when I
press that button you're taking that
wallet address and you're scanning I'm
assuming hundreds if not thousands of
websites and various locations for has
this wallet address been presented
anywhere so could be on Twitter it could
be on the dark web etc and really again
it sounds like you're trying to present
as much information as possible so
people can make an evaluation as to
should I act send money here or should I
do business with whoever owns this
wallet or not yeah that's right we just
wanted individuals to have as much
information as they can to make an
informed decision when I was in the
Secret Service they teach firearms check
check twice I'm sure you heard the same
thing in the military so I think when
you send crypto you've got to check
check twice you got to make sure that
address is going somewhere that you
trust and so we want to give users the
most information they can have in their
hand when they when they send crypto and
most people these days are using their
phone with QR codes you can use a QR
code scan with our phone there's a lot
of really good things I think from a
consolidation standpoint that app users
can do and then we added the receive
notifications and I thought from a
business perspective if you if you have
an account where you're constantly
getting donations or you run a store you
don't you'll need to constantly check
your account you can set up a
notification through the app and plenty
goes in or out you're gonna get a
notification mm-hmm and is the thought
process here that individuals eventually
kind of get educated and trained on the
fact
you know check before you send or does
this eventually get kind of incorporated
into the exchanges and kind of wallet
providers etc yeah I think yes so both
of those I mean my hope is that we can
have an API ready for this
first of the year where companies that
have wallets for individuals can opt in
and say hey would you like to use this
API to check a risk score you know
obviously there's a lot of liability
comes with that we can't catch every
address but we can give you as much
information as possible so I think the
the opportunities on this side are
pretty expansive when you look at the
market and then you know we plan on
having a enterprise-grade product that
will be coming out next year but all
right our focus right now is on the
users because there's no one right there
no one right now that has anything out
there that's consolidating data to help
them make a good decision yeah and it
feels like to me
as you see the kind of digitization of
whether it's national currencies or the
kind of proliferation of like these
stable coins etc this all this
technology becomes much more important
right and I always go back to this idea
of Bitcoin can be private if you know
what you're doing right so the use of
mixers and kind of all that stuff but
the staple coins and the digital dollars
etc they're promises not privacy right
their promise is actually the exact
opposite but of course just like any
monetary system people are going to have
these scams people are going to do
criminal stuff etc and so providing the
tools to necessarily prevent but educate
people so that they can take the actions
to not participate in these I think it's
really important and frankly people just
don't think about that right right right
how do you see that playing out right in
terms of the government's looking and
saying hey there is nefarious activity
happening with Bitcoin or manera or
whatever we want to digitize our
currency does that play in at all or
what do you think they're thinking there
yeah I think it's interesting because I
think before Libra had to testify David
Marcus from Facebook the conversation
was there but it was not on a more
national level so now you have
congressional Senate committees looking
at it and I think the whole leap Lieber
lon
was great for the industry because it
made the people that need to talk about
it talk about I mean we heard the
president of United States mention
Bitcoin who would have thought crazy
crazy right I mean we heard the
Secretary of Treasury mentioned Bitcoin
and so a lot of people saw that is bad
because maybe it wasn't in a positive
light but I saw that is good because
eventually they're gonna start talking
to people that handle this type of stuff
they're gonna talk to their Secret
Service guys they're gonna talk to the
FBI they're gonna talk to the Treasury
and they're gonna say okay what's the
deal with this is it bad do criminals
use it the answer that's gonna be
yeah criminals use it but it's a small
percentage it actually has great
technology behind it and the underlying
protocols could could really make things
more efficient so I think the digitized
dollar is a really fascinating thing and
it could be really a really timely thing
and I think if you take a step back from
a geopolitical perspective right after
the Libra thing you see China say hey
we're Pro blockchain we we want to be
innovative we're gonna create all these
programs for you and then all of a
sudden it's well that's not exactly
happening you know I think that was
maybe a shot to the bow the United
States to say well why you're hamming up
Libre we're over here trying to be
innovative and so it's very interesting
I think that we could see a not
initially an arms race but a digitized
dollar raced across governments to try
to be the first first to do it it's like
the space race yeah becomes the yeah
called the great currency race right
which is like who's going to be the
first to digitize and it's about
accessibility right so certain people
can't get access to dollars or the yen
or whatever if somebody is able to get
them access because now I only need an
internet connection pretty big deal
but then you don't just hit the US in
China right you see the French central
bank so they're gonna start testing this
in q1 right with kind of select partners
the ECB is now talking about like oh the
staple coin thing we're gonna have to
have a plan there right okay a fun fact
that I did not know until recently
Christine Lagarde who's the president of
the ECB if you google her name and look
on her we could be pedia page she's
listed as a politician and lawyer really
so it says you know president of the ECB
and politician lawyer whatever and so
it's just as funny to me that like
politicians are determining monetary
policy right and so I think that
there's this idea of Technology
intersecting with monetary policy or
central bank activity but the
ramifications of that are quite serious
I think for the the everyday person also
law enforcement has to stay on top of
this right regulators have to stay on
top of the successor so it's not just do
we do it or do we not it's do we do it
and then what's the impact of all this
right right as you're thinking through
kind of the the regulatory technology
that gets built and and side-chain etc
where are the areas in that that you
think people are not yet building but
are gonna become important over the next
couple years well I think if you look at
some of the I guess the movements in the
crypto space since bitcoins come out you
know 2017 was the big ICO craze where
you know everybody is launching on
etherium now fast forward the the big I
think of 2018 was what stable coins and
all that 2019 towards the end has been
decentralize the central has financed
moving into 2020 and so I think that's
gonna be a really big push to where
crypto starts becoming more mainstream
because a lot of the government's were
looking at this now you think of crypto
Valley in Switzerland I mean they're
really big in this space they have a lot
of I think over a thousand blockchain
companies there they have a lot of good
banking systems obviously so I think
we're gonna see this decentralize
finance movement really move the
industry another step forward and so I
think a lot of good things are to come
and we're still early I think in Bitcoin
in the technology for sure and speaking
of technology I want to throw a couple
things out at you and get clarification
having you sat in that kind of
law-enforcement seat so the first thing
I hear is the privacy coins are
trackable right so Zee cash Manero etc
what was kind of the efficacy from the
law enforcement side of of those what
are deemed privacy coins but are they
actually private or how did you guys
think about those so for for Zee cash
for instance you know you look at Jim
and I and Cooling base listed them
pretty early and it's because they had
the non shielded version of Z cash they
have your non prophecy lay in your
privacy layer and I think from I'm just
guessing they did that so they could be
regulator friendly because you can turn
it on and off Manero is a whole
different ballgame I mean it's a very
interesting project
they were so there's
decentralized that even when they had a
I think some malware inserted in their
website they said well we can't fix it
were these centralized we're gonna get
to it and I was really shocked to hear
that but they're very decentralized so
on the same on the same side you know I
wasn't so you know they're very true to
their thought on that but the whole
privacy coins are gonna be very
interesting because from a Bitcoin
perspective if we look at and say ok if
we see some type of adoption down the
road where it's probably be awhile in
the United States but other countries
that have inflation issues where their
currency continues to be devalued and
they need some something that's more
stable well if you're in a country like
that and you're running a storefront
that's a bodega or something the
government should know how much business
you're doing on a daily basis so by
default the privacy layer on bitcoins
not there but you have other coins that
they are so I think it's gonna be
interesting to see how how the
government looks at that in the future
going forward because privacy is
important it should be about default you
know there's the reason we have the
fourth amendment these things that the
government shouldn't just be able to
look at everything they should have to
have a reason to do so it's really
important point and having been in
military right a lot of my friends have
gone into law enforcement in various
capacities federal organizations or even
defense contractors etc and I think a
lot of people believe because we live in
this world of like the Patriot Act and
kind of senator or congressman Warren
Davidson's recent podcast we basically
empowered the banks to become spies on
their customers right and kind of all
this information that now is maybe
encroaching to some of those liberal our
individual liberties and freedoms the
people who are participating in this
right who are working at the law
enforcement agencies who work in the
military sector they actually believe in
the individual freedoms and liberties
more than most right because they've
seen kind of the other side of it and so
this idea that having worked at the
Secret Service and seeing what happens
when you're doing investigations etc the
privacy of financial transactions is
still important to you right like you
still I think it's because this core
tenets of like it should be the default
and I think that for those people who've
never talked to somebody who's had your
experiences or kind of working those
organizations
like oh those guys don't care about
privacy it's like it no actually exact
opposite right they usually care really
really deeply about privacy as a default
because they've seen kind of the other
side of the coin if you will yeah you're
exactly right and I think 10 years ago
when we thought about this whole privacy
thing we we never there were probably
some early people that said hey this is
gonna be a problem but that's certainly
ten years ago I didn't think about all
this stuff about how how big privacy was
gonna come into play on electronics your
everyday if you think about your app
everybody's always tracking you in some
in some form or fashion so you can't
shut it off you can't shut it off you
really can it so from the privacy
perspective I think we're really in a
critical point especially the United
States and what we're gonna do you've
got these backdoor [ __ ] Shin laws that
are coming forward you've got all these
other challenges where you know we're
looking at countries that have Authority
M type regimes that they need these type
of technology so they can have evade
some pretty ridiculous things so I think
we're in a very interesting challenge to
see how we're gonna respond and privacy
is definitely a paramount of what we
were founded upon you know you think
back several hundred years ago and what
we were founded upon and things that
we're supposed to be living by so I've
got faith that we're gonna do the right
thing in the long run and that it's just
gonna take time to play out because
governments are bureaucratic by nature
they've got to make sure that
everything's right and so I'm confident
we're gonna get to the right place it
just makes me take some time for sure
what about mixers like how how did you
guys think about the mixers either as
for you guys to use or as other people
that maybe you were investigating we're
using them yeah I think we have a
conversation before we started my first
experience with the mixer is I sent some
undercover funds to the wrong mixer and
got scammed myself but you know mixers
are interesting because you know I've
seen the the tactics on how they mix
funds on the dark web change as law
enforcement changes their technology and
catch up so you know mixers you know I'm
very Pro a technology that's private you
shouldn't have to do all these extra
steps and so I I think for me happen to
use a mixer to try to hide my
transactions it's just too much effort
mhm and there's a lot of risk but it's
important if you're one to hide your
hide your transactions I get that for
privacy but from a criminal perspective
no mixers are only going to continue to
improve
and it's gonna be a challenge for law
enforcement you know they're not looking
for the pumps out there that are trying
to you know just live their own life and
not tell everybody how much Bitcoin they
have or how much they don't have in my
case and and when you look at these
criminals law enforcement are going to
continually have a challenge to catch up
to that technology and I think that's
the that's the biggest question mark
because when you think about the worst
crimes like the child predators the
terrorist attacks we have the pendulum
Swift after 9/11 it was super aggressive
and then we came back a little bit then
there's another attack pendulum went
right back at the Boston bombings
pendulum swift again and so I think we
constantly have that in the US but right
now the focus on privacy is just at a
point where you know there's a lot of
people rightfully so in the crypto space
they're very nervous yeah well in part
of this I think is I don't think a lot
of people disagree on what the intended
end result of all this is right so right
we want to provide prevent terrorist
attacks we want to prevent criminal
activity we want to basically provide
safe fair marketplaces like all of that
as a intended end result we all
generally think is a good thing all
right where the discrepancies happen or
the disagreements is how do we get there
right and there's a balance between
making it not impossible for law
enforcement and also not violating the
freedoms and rights and privacy of
everyone and I recently read Edward
Snowden's book permanent record and it
was fascinating to hear how some of the
systems work how he thought about
building the systems and then flipping
around on the other side and basically
being so anti than that he ends up
whistleblowing etc and the thing I took
away from all of it is humans are
interacting with technology that they
don't understand and therefore they
don't even understand the data right and
the violations of the privacy because
they don't realize the data is being
created and you see this every once in a
while there's really like every year
there's like a Business Insider article
that goes viral all over again it's like
Google Maps is tracking you people are
like wait what do you mean right and
it's like here's how to turn it off
head and it cracks me up with every year
there's you know a two-week period where
like the article goes viral right
and it's like hey guys it's not just
Google Maps it's also Apple maps and
Facebook and every single app you have
on your phone is usually persistently
using location or other kind of data
collection to better target ads for
whatever the part to me that feels like
it won't change is at some point there's
that trade-off between privacy and
convenience right and line like that
that is a a very blurred line yeah that
I think most people will pick
convenience over the privacy cuz they
don't understand it privacy and and you
know having sat in your seat it'd be
interesting to hear your thoughts I'm
like how should people think about that
right Norton maybe there's even things
that you do that kind of enhance your
privacy that either change the
convenient so or don't yeah so I mean
what for passwords for instance my
passwords are obnoxious I just ride them
down I have them stored somewhere and I
don't use common passwords and I think
that's one thing you gotta start from
your very basic cyber hygiene is use a
very good password
you know don't use I love basketball or
Bitcoin for life or Bitcoin for life or
one and then 90 days Bitcoin for life or
two or you know so I think I say that
because we you know you see that so
often and a lot of these data breaches
the password Bitcoin for is with the
number four right yeah you know I think
if we look at the password protected
that's something you've always got to do
when you connect to public Wi-Fi I say
don't hotspot from your phone if you can
or if you're gonna use public Wi-Fi
always use a VPN always use a VPN so
what goes on there when you connect to
the public Wi-Fi what are some of the
big concerns yeah so you never know if
the Wi-Fi you're connecting to is maybe
just a fake access point where an
individual so you could be to Starbucks
cafe and it could say Starbucks one and
really it's it's your buddy Joe over
there collecting all of your information
and they're looking at traffic so you
have tools out there and public Wi-Fi
where I can sit down there and I can
view all the traffic going in and out
and then I can start organizing an
attack and so looking at your the
traffic on a public Wi-Fi is a very easy
way to identify
on the target and in that case so let's
say I think most people would say all
right I'm not gonna use my credit card
I'm public Wi-Fi right so I'm not gonna
buy something online but that's only one
piece of it right it's basically if you
logged into your email they see your
password right or get your username or
or credentials to a service or that type
of stuff that it's worried about words
or even more kind of nuanced pieces of
information that these people are
looking for other than just username
passwords and different service
credentials yeah I think username and
passwords are probably the biggest ones
out there you know because typically if
you catch one password you've caught all
their accounts because it's just a
common thing like you say convenience is
no one wants to have a different
password for every service I understand
it but if you're gonna do that which is
not a good idea what are you gonna do as
a second layer do you have two-factor
authentication if you do don't make it
text messaging let's use 2fa right
there's also external keys Google Titan
has a great great key that you can use
for your email and it's there's been
times where I've been traveling I didn't
have my tight and I got logged out and
you know I I was stuck that's not good
so you've got to think about these
challenges and and build a gets a
balance risk approach you'll love this
so I recently got a a phone switched out
and I couldn't remember the password to
my email right right and it was logged
in on one device and not one device I
was literally waking up every morning I
get in and I eventually remembered what
the password was but as I went through
it it I spent a whole basically what two
weeks I think it was without email on my
phone and during that two-week period
multiple times
I would go and I think I remember the
password right and I was scared I was
gonna to lock myself out yeah right
because I try to figure out what it is
but when you have that or you have to FA
on your phone you'll have your phone
with you you can't get in etc you got to
get comfortable understanding like it's
working yeah right like that's not an
inconvenience is actually know the
security works right and I think that
again people they want the convenience
yeah the security and privacy ends up
being really really
especially encrypt up oh yeah well did
you guys deal with the sim swapping at
all do you guys see that a lot yeah so
you know a lot of the guests in Silicon
Valley are you have a lot of big-time
CEOs that are very interested in crypto
and so we would see these bad actors
that would just target these individuals
relentlessly and they would symptoms
there's a very good task force in I
think it's Santa Clara I can't remember
the name sorry if they're listening
maybe react but but you know best in the
country in my opinion they're doing a
lot of really great work at targeting
these sim sim swappers but it's one of
those things you can set up a 15
character password you can tell 80 to
ask a question who's my favorite
podcaster and how the answer be Manero
but the end of the day it comes down to
the insider threat you know is the
employee can they be bought
who has access the information you know
I had a conversation last week with a
carrier and I said hey I want to make my
phone as secure as possible what can I
do well you can build in a long password
you can have a question that has a
different answer I said okay now what
happens if someone goes in the store at
the fake ID well they have to still get
your questions answered right and I said
well what happens if the employee just
gives them my answers well I guess your
system is defeated so what what am I
supposed to do is Housewife secure yeah
so essentially there's a new company out
there called don't port and I've been
talking to their CEO so don't support
don't port and brand new you know he's
just getting started out but he's he's
trying to tackle this industry where
there's like a 10 to 12 step
authentication port out process to where
you've got to do all these different
steps to swap your phone over and it
also comes with a two million dollar
insurance policy and so I've been
talking to him trying to think if I want
to do that or not but you know even I'm
struggling with okay well now I got to
swap my phone over again you know I'm I
hate going through all that all that
stuff even if it's a different sim swap
but the other thing that's interesting
on the swim saw sim swap side is over
the last five to seven years that's how
attackers in these traditional financial
crimes would take over accounts because
banks still use text messaging for 2fa
so this is not new it's just new because
everyone in crypto talks about it well
in this new
because in the sense of there's bearer
assets now yeah right yeah if somebody
got my you know Wells Fargo account and
transferred some money out yeah it
sucked but I called the bank it was like
hey idiots yeah so he just stole some
money for it they would usually fix it
pretty quickly and so you know kind of
defeated the purpose of the criminal
activity or there was a deep being said
the incentives were lower when all of a
sudden if as long as they get the money
you can't get it back yeah huge problem
right yeah and that's what's interesting
is I'm wondering if there's gonna be a
time where right now exchanges are
taking a step back and they're saying
you're your own bank you're responsible
but Wells Fargo you get scammed you go
the wrong website somebody steals your
card they give you the money back
because they're FDIC insured you know
when you look at the Libre testimony
David Marcus made a comment I can't
remember word for word but he talked
about how you know they're gonna look at
how they can make their customers whole
and I wrote a very small blog on this
and I thought this is very substantial
this is great for the industry because
it shows that there's a new player in
town and they're willing to look at a
way to fight fraud and make their
customers whole and that's that's my
struggle with the crypto industry right
now is they they say you got to be your
own bank but what happens when there's
your human you know you go to the wrong
website well okay you're out 5,000
dollars and so I think there's some
things that we're gonna see in the
industry over the next few years where
they may be forced to do some things or
maybe there's gonna be some that come
out front and say okay we're not FDIC
insured but we've got our own insurance
policy and we're gonna do our own
investigation it's gonna cost this money
we're gonna have to hire a hundred more
people to verify you actually were
defrauded but we're gonna do the right
thing and we want to make sure people
are taken care of yeah and you saw this
with finance when they got hacked right
yeah you know forty million dollars or
so and then they basically had a fund
that it was their own insurance policies
right right and they replaced it but but
to me it's um it's really interesting
too because of the user interfaces and
user experiences suck right so you know
the whole idea of I'm gonna send my
Bitcoin to a random string of letters
and numbers right becomes pretty easy to
screw that up yeah right and and I
always your point about like check and
check twice
I think people know that they should do
that I really wonder how many people are
actually doing it yeah I don't think
that it's as many people as people want
you to believe you are checking and
checking twice that random string but
it's easy to send it to the wrong
address
and all of a sudden that's not fraud
that's just stupidity yeah right and so
should you know should the exchange be
on the hook for your stupidity where
should you there's people who are gonna
argue both sides of that yeah but I
think that that's a whole nother kind of
you know can of worms if you will then
just hey somebody scammed me oh yeah
yeah agree yeah I just remembered a
story regarding sim swaps so a guy that
I arrested several years ago ended up
tracking me down a couple months ago on
my personal phone and you know I feel
like I've taken some pretty good
precautions but you know it's really
funny the person calls me of is that a
Joe McGill yes
special agent McGee yes hey this is
so-and-so how you doing hey I'm well how
are you doing we're you investigated and
arrested a dude I'm assuming went to
jail come back couple years later and he
calls you on your personal cell phone
yes what's going through your head at
that point uh it caught me really
off-guard but you know it's interesting
I had a good relationship with this guy
I wanted him a work full-time for the
Secret Service my mentality was if you
catch somebody that's really talented
it's just business they let them do the
time but if we can make them work their
time off and and get more people that
don't care that they're hurting victims
let's do it and so it was an interesting
interesting thing it's more of a
professional business relationship and
crazy it caught me off guard my wife was
in the kitchen she looked at me and she
could see my face I probably was pale as
a ghost and if he hears his podcast he's
probably laughing laughing right now but
yeah caught me off guard I thought you
know I've done all these extra security
precautions but at the end of the day if
they want to find you
they're gonna find you your digital
footprints been out there for ten years
and you know when I asked him how he did
it he's like well you arrested me in
California but have you heard yourself
talk you're definitely from the south
you know you're not from California so
he used my you know my southern accent
it gets me to try to you know take out
states that I may not be
lived in so as wild unbelievable yeah
unbelievable I'm always amazed at
there's some of these services and I
forget the name of them but the I won't
say who they are because I don't know if
they'd be comfortable but uh I know a
company that their sales team they've
got these tools where they can pretty
much get anyone's email or cell phone
number and now they're not doing
anything nefarious whether they're
basically just gonna harass the [ __ ] out
of you for you to buy their service
whatever right but they showed it to me
one day and I was like you know you
start picking you know the bill gates
right and obviously there's some people
who information not there but you'd be
shocked it you know there's some pretty
big names out there that literally
you're staring at it and I remember I
said to them what about this company
Google real quick from the founder and I
said I get to give me their cell phone
over mhm and handed to me and and we
called founder picked up when it wasn't
a you know somebody that people would
know right so it's just I think but I
remember sitting there thinking like
holy [ __ ] yeah right
the ability to use a freemium tool right
so you actually do much surges for free
before gotta pay and get that level of
information and then once you have it
that the pain that that person would
have to go through to switch the number
yeah right is pretty damn hot oh yeah it
becomes this whole thing where like no
wonder you gets my robo calls yeah right
like Jesus they're doing this for a
living right so it's pretty crazy to see
what's what's next for for what you guys
are building in terms of you guys kind
of have what I'll call that the address
lookup and all the information along
with it but uh other than the API what
else you guys want to build so we've got
an enterprise platform is gonna come out
hopefully sometime quarter to next year
and so we're hoping to get into the race
with all the other big guys you know
there are five years and about a hundred
million dollars ahead and you know
they've been collecting data for a while
but the industry industry is huge and so
you know I'm confident we can get in
there and so I'm hoping to take things I
learned at The Secret Service and the
wish list of things I wanted in these
tools and talking to other people and
then built into this platform and so
we're gonna use that to hopefully help
financial institutions in law
enforcement be compliant
identify criminals and and so that's
that's the next step after the apps out
and so I'm really excited about that
awesome that sounds great before I wrap
up I always asked rapid-fire questions
what uh what's the most important
company in crypto other than your own
most important company in crypto wow
that's that's an interesting one I would
say you know a lot of people look to the
big exchanges in the United States I
don't want to publicly name one of them
because I don't act like I'm endorsing
one but you know there's exchanges in
the United States that I think are gonna
really assure the way that we deal with
regulation because they're trying to
operate within the lines instead of
outside the lines and then get you know
slap and then recorrect so I think
there's a couple companies in the u.s.
in San Francisco and then here in New
York they're gonna really make this
mainstream and do a lot of good things
there's one in New York whose guy's
[ __ ] ads run around saying crypto
needs rules yeah yeah you're right so
you may be onto one of those that uh you
know I'm not officially naming but yeah
I think I think those type of companies
are really gonna do a lot of good things
for the space cool one of my favorite
questions to ask people and I'm really
interested in your answer is what's the
one regulation or law you would change
or improve if you could oh yeah I got
one so a few years ago there's a bill
introduced that crypto currency
transactions under $600 would not be
taxed you know I just bought a coffee
downstairs a bluebottle it's been about
a 12 month drought and if I would have
used crypto I would have to pay capital
gains tax on that and so I would love to
see a bill that comes out that says hey
any any transaction under this amount
there's no capital gains tax and I think
that's gonna help people the common
sense bail go off like guys like Mark
Cuban you talked about like why would
anybody want to use crypto when they're
gonna get taxed on a cup of coffee you
know why am I gonna buy a house for a
million dollars if I'm gonna have to pay
capital gains tax or you know why don't
want to get paid and crypto if I'm gonna
get federal income tax and then capital
gains tax for paying my rent so let's
get a bill out there and let's get some
people that have money to get lobbyists
and let's let's get a bill out there
that helps people use crypto on a daily
basis for sure now makes sense what is
the most important book you've ever read
let's say the Bible that's the most
important book
for sure impacted my life early on it's
it's a foundation in which I operate and
my faith so yeah definitely the Bible
I've said this before hi guys I'm
shocked at how few times that book comes
up like and I don't know if it's a I've
always wondered is it because people are
like embarrassed right they don't want
to talk about religion and their beliefs
etc or is it just becoming less popular
right and it might be a little bit of
both
but that's questions specifically I
would think the Bible comes up more than
it does and it just doesn't yeah I think
it's interesting you know you look at
the last 15 years it's the faith of
which this country was founded on it has
been on a decline it's not it's not a
popular thing right now and so you know
faith is a big part of my life and I'm
not afraid to talk about it at all the
people who believe are usually not right
what about aliens believe or not believe
it going from God to aliens so your part
when I saw a few months ago you're
posting up podcasts like man that guy I
mean he's he's got everything out there
that is awesome I don't know they it
terrifies me because you see these you
know these videos from I think the Navy
released some videos and there's these
objects and man it terrifies me I don't
know so you're already going on the path
of I don't know if we want the aliens to
come here right yeah exactly yeah you're
right yeah like and if you listen to
some of these guys I'm gonna forget
their names now but uh these guys who
basically there's people who argue like
aliens like you would think you know
Independence Day type stuff where it's
like a little green slamming the guy
right mm-hmm
okay maybe maybe not whatever but then
there's people who basically say no I
have or I saw or I learned about this
thing that has properties we can't
explain so whether it's you see the Navy
pilots talking about you know the way
that something moved right and they're
just like there's no way something go
from zero to a you know a hundred and
fifty miles an hour like that we're hope
repulsion below whatever okay or you
talk to one of these guys who now have
come out who's supposedly worked at area
51 and they're like look we basically
had
flying saucers that you know could do
things that we couldn't explain and the
physics or you've got a guy like Tom
DeLonge though she was the blink-182 guy
who's like hey man I got a rock the rock
has things that people can't explain
like right right
and it's funny really laughing about it
but also there's like wait a minute why
can't we explain what that is yeah yeah
and it's more science driven like
experimentation that to me super
interesting because it's like you know
there was a point where we couldn't
explain gravity or you know whatever and
then we learn that stuff but we know we
aren't here alone in the audience of
like there's the earth and there's other
stuff well there's other stuff like at
some point is there intelligent life
yeah it's scary to think about right
yeah well in the part that gets me is we
always forget how far this stuff is yeah
right like you know we see Elon launch
these rockets or hey that thing went
pretty fast
right and it's like by the way if you
got in that rocket you wouldn't make it
to Mars before you died you're like wait
a minute I was like 50 here yeah right
like it you start to think through some
of the stuff and understand how big it
is it's like oh [ __ ] like how small we
are right matter yeah right we're
insignificant in the whole grand scheme
with well giving your book answer
there's a guy Bruce Fenton who I love
Bruce but I'll give him a little [ __ ]
that he's he's a little out there when
it comes to some of his theories as to
aliens and and he cites ancient aliens
was the whole thing but what he said to
me as he goes look every human has two
questions in life what happens after we
die and are we here alone yeah and it's
like yeah that I think that's probably
pretty accurate as to what people want
to know yeah you're right right what one
question you have for me to finish up so
what got you into crypto oh man there's
a there's a saying that I've heard a
couple of people say and I forget who
originally said it so I apologize but I
came for the money and I stayed for the
money right right I came for the money
meaning there was some allure of there
was profits right and I think that
probably draws in ninety ninety five
percent of people right and I don't want
to admit that yeah but that's what
brought them in right they came
across there's very few people I think
in your shoes who like discover it and
become interested because there's part
of their job right right
maybe that's becoming a little bit more
popular today but definitely not earlier
on but that I stayed for the money is
this whole idea of we don't educate
people on money right I wrote recently
that like money is too dangerous an idea
for school all right right we're like we
can't educate everyone on how the
monetary financial system works right
it's the Henry Ford quote like if
everyone knew how the banks work there'd
be a revolution before the morning right
yeah it's stealing wealth you guys are
basically you have a whole system built
in rich ourselves and screw everybody
else yeah and so I think that like
that's one thing that Bitcoin has really
done is educate an entire generation or
some portion of that generation on what
is money how does it work you know what
it sound money where the downsides of
the fiat it kind of inflationary system
what are the other options etc and my
hope is that price continues to go
through these boom and bust cycles and
when it booms lots of people rush in
right and yes some people gonna leave
right because they're only there for a
price but there is a good amount of
people who are gonna stick around
because of all the more structural
issues around money and I think we're
seeing that play out you know kind of
through these cycles but the nice thing
is that the cycles get bigger now yeah
right there what used to be kind of
10,000 new people come in and learn
about this stuff now it's you know
millions of people where you know
coinbase in 2017 was signing up a
hundred thousand people a day that's
insane
what how's that possible right it's just
well and to me it's it's crazy in the
sense of like price drives that right
price drives word of mouth word of mouth
drives the virality the virality drives
traffic the traffic signs up right which
drives price which you know it's like
this self-fulfilling thing but like
that's how markets work yeah and so it's
it's kind of like this times not
different it's just like every other
time but people just gotta remember
that's how the markets work oh so where
can people find you other than your
personal cell phone number and and more
about the company sidechain calm at cyc
haan sidechain calm
all right Twitter at Joe's Jay OES
underscore McGill mcgi ll what's up with
the ass
Joe was taken so you only chose I went
with Joe's that's pretty good yeah so in
about a domain Joe's McGill as well
because it matches my Twitter and
evidently Twitter is what runs the world
now because is that gonna be a thing now
if you aren't gonna be able to get their
social media handle there's gonna change
the name I think they're gonna have to
write I mean I would love to be Joe
McGill but someone out there took it so
he took it yeah I will I'm gonna give a
shout-out to my guy at pomp this dude
I'm gonna keep calling him out until he
knocks out the nonsense he he's got at
pomp on Twitter on Instagram eccentric
come on he's blocked me happy really
because everyone keeps tagging them
right and so he finally DMV one day and
he goes how much right now I was like
what and I get my email emails me and my
I want to sell it because I'm getting
off social media I said great thing just
give it to me for free I need it was
make a deal he's like not a how how much
this is very valuable well as I did look
you got about a market a one right yeah
I'm pretty much the only person in the
world who wants this yeah you and me and
if you're leaving then it's gonna be
worthless
and inside I'd start getting a hard time
in kind of a playful way and I wouldn't
have looked he's like a DJ like jockey
and like on the radio and he's a pastor
- Wow and I was like man you're killing
life yeah but I'm not changing my name
I'm just gonna get the handle so Joe's
underscore McGill that's right awesome
in alright what they you source are
coming to do this I really appreciate it
yeah hope people go check out side chain
and and hopefully you guys keep building
it up yeah thanks for having me I
appreciate it for sure